in this video we'll talk about the
Hallmarks of cancer experts throughout
the world sat together and Define six
Hallmarks of cancer
and these six Hallmarks are
resisting cell death because cancer
cells upregulated programs which prevent
apoptosis
and promote survival
so the second Hallmark is sustained
proliferative signaling and the third
Hallmark is evading growth suppressor
so there are signalings that promote
proliferation division and growth and
there are also signaling Pathways that
suppress uncontrolled growth cancer cell
can evade the suppressor and it can
responds more to the proliferative
signals both this phenomena
lead to an uncontrolled proliferation of
the cancer cells
also cancer cells can metastasize that
means it can move from one place to
another and this happens via a process
known as epithelial to mesenchymal
transition
also cancer cell has a property of
replicative immortality that they can
divide for eternity and they are kind of
immortal
and lastly cancer cells can induce
angiogenesis that means they can induce
formation of new blood vessels in the
tumor that would allow more nutrient and
oxygen into this tumor that would
increase the chances of survivility of
that cancer so these are the six
Hallmarks in this video we'll talk about
these six Hallmarks in bit more details
so let's take our normal cell and the
cancer cell and try to ask what is
different between these two cell types
so the most important thing that is
different is uncontrolled growth and
proliferation but why the growth is
uncontrolled or proliferation is more
and this is because the signaling
Pathways that controlled growth or
proliferation or cell division that are
faulty in cancer cells so there are two
category of genetic mechanism which
promotes growth and suppress growth for
example proto-oncogenes are generally
promoting growth and they induce growth
cell proliferation and division whereas
tumor suppressor chain act in opposite
fashion it prevents uncontrolled growth
now if there is a mutation in oncogene
or there is a mutation tumor suppressor
Gene that might lead to uncontrolled
growth and division
which is a leading cause of cancer
just to give you a specific idea map
kinase pathway is one of the key growth
signaling pathway it promotes cell
division and cell proliferation in this
case the mitogen or a growth factor
binds to the receptor and the cell
responds to this kind of nitrogen by
up-regulating the gene which are
important for proliferation in this case
a gtpa is known as Ras is really
important
but rash is shut off after some time in
normal scenarios by GTP as activator
protein but when there is a mutation in
Ras that leads to
non-hydrolyzable GTP
that would activate the signaling for a
very long time so the signaling would
happen and the genes regulating growth
survival and proliferation would be
upregulated and it would lead to an
uncontrolled proliferation which is the
key cause of cancer
don't think it's only map kinase pathway
there are many other Pathways which are
underlying cancer it turns out that the
target genes such as ccnd1 cmic BCL
Excel all of these genes can be
expressed Downstream to many signaling
pathway such as wind betacatinine
signaling pathway such as receptor
tyrosine kinase based signaling pi3 akt
signaling pathway
check stat signaling pathway tgfp does
signaling pathway or even not signaling
pathway so there are many signaling
pathway which can lead to proliferation
and when things go wrong
it lead to over proliferation and that
leads to cancer
okay sometimes the Machinery that
prevents
uncontrolled growth is faulty and that
leads to cancer for example when there
is a double stranded DNA break
sensors like ATM would bind there and
recruit p53 which is a tumor suppressor
protein p53 prevents the cell cycle
progression and p53 do so with the help
of p21 kinase and that prevents the
cyclin and cdk4 activity
but imagine a situation when p53 is
mutated in that case
the cyclins cannot be inhibited that
means even if there is a DNA break the
cell cycle would progress
so the cell there would be new cells
produced with lot of new mutations which
is a leading cause of cancer
now another important Hallmark of cancer
is angiogenesis because this huge mass
of cells need more oxygen nutrients to
survive and new blood vessel Generations
can help them to thrive and cancer cells
secrete substances which can trigger or
induce angiogenesis
there are another important factor about
cancer is metastasis metastasis means a
cancer cell can leave its current
environment move through the blood
vessel or lymph node and can reach
another location in the body
metastasis is the situation which makes
it very difficult to treat cancer
because you try to treat or eliminate
cancer from one part of the body by
surgical removal radiation or anything
but the cancer cells move to another
location and start a new tumor that is
why cancer is so hard and difficult to
treat
so in this video in short we have looked
at all the six Hallmarks of cancer
you can find more notes and flashcards
in my Instagram and Facebook page
support us via super tanks see you in
next video
foreign